no one man should have all that what
heart kanye's dropping out of the race
what why his last few years have already
been so much fun and it was only gonna
get funner I mean with him we're gonna
watch the trailer for project power
another superhero project from Netflix
the writer of the Batman and the
directors of one of the good Paranormal
Activity movies let's check this out
before we do that I am obliged to tell
you by no one I just want to tell you
Talon and follow us on that damn
Stardust app posting all the freaking
time so much so much so you'll get sick
of it but it'll be worth it yeah cuz
it's free and 30-second reviews for
films TV shows and trailers catching up
on so much [ __ ] during quarantine yeah
download follow us first tag us share an
opinion then John might read it I might
I do
[Music]
oh wow
Masika Kelly yes what yes I'm taking it
why would I not take it that's really
[Music]
sweet
Casey nice tattoo
whoa detective John Blake that was one
of the best-looking him that kind of
effect upgrade
[Music]
[Music]
I hope there's an extended sex scene
between the two yeah man Netflix is
struggling to produce content during
covin nineteen men they're really having
a rough time what are they gonna do they
did not have enough in their catalog to
get them through these months just
literally thinking to myself man they're
probably sitting real pretty right now
if everyone made such a big deal about
not being you know hemorrhaging money
basically and now they're like winning
every weekend cuz of the only people
released I love this trailer I really do
I think it's pretty badass I've been
watching so much superhero content I
just finished all of Umbrella Academy
started up doing patrol I'm all in this
zone right now high-octane violent
r-rated edgy superhero absorption at the
moment I think if you go on Stardust I
believe you finally started the boy what
oh that's true I started the band I am
very much enjoying now so finally so my
point with that is like what what
television is doing and this is not a TV
show it's kind of a bummer he's losing
it would be a pretty sick but it also
looks like it could have been a great
limited release superhero film in the
theaters which is you know a bummer to
experience but as it stands I think in
terms of the visual effects Department
it looks pretty badass I'm excited for
Jamie Foxx to be doing this type of
character again and Joseph gordon-levitt
there were two times I thought of other
Joseph gordon-levitt movies it was in
this abandoned Robin because you're like
come on man I'm Blake during our other
and then the other time was when they're
in the van and their hands are up here
like Inception
yeah just like Arnold references he
looks great the whole cast looks pretty
awesome
I'm Kelly yeah man he's finally he's
proving [ __ ] waters weird
he's gonna prove what a badass he is by
being in this Hollywood motion picture
yeah let's hope so maybe he can beef
with M & M on screen this does have a
bit of all the shows that I reference
from the boys umbrella Academy and Doom
Patrol it seems to have a bit of a
hodgepodge of all of it because this
could be happening down the street from
the boys are bright or like having you
know yeah because I love the concept
though the pill that they're they're
doing is like I was just gonna do like a
limitless thing where you're home lock
your mind or whatever percent they said
like five minutes is how long you could
have the power for I love that ticking
time clock to every single time someone
will have a power activated I don't know
what the world will lend itself to if
you know they they're able to adapt the
power permanently or there's some
prolonged effect or lasts longer than
five minutes instantly be this
high-octane pulse-pounding effect when
someone has a superpower activated
because you know there's a time limit on
just the five minutes oh and there's so
much you can do with the idea that yeah
everybody reacts differently to it so
you know there's even potential for
comedy there and partly wonders too just
in the lore of the world you know is
that the kind of thing where every time
you take it it's the same or will
introduce some sort of different formula
partway through to allows you to shift
or change I feel like especially now
anytime where you have like powers that
can be manipulated by science someone is
gonna come up with a plot to combine all
the powers into one mega power and then
I'm gonna have the power but uh yeah
like the villainous element seems cliche
yeah but I don't think you're gonna tune
in for that yeah looks really crude like
at least as a trailer goes it looks
really crisp and really tight I mean I
feel like some of the stuff we saw
probably carries through too close too
late into the movie force and so yeah it
looks like it has insane production
values great action good performances by
people who know what level the movies on
and yeah this was like a slam dunk in
terms of just getting me excited for an
experience well these guys did the movie
nerve I get a little bit of that
directing style infused in here the
Batman will be a completely different
kind of superhero movie that being said
I mean the guy wrote the bad
and any road this and if people people
are gonna watch this obviously way
earlier than the Bevins comes out next
month and I think if this goes well
they'll get people even more excited for
the Batman oh yeah yeah I have to see
what level of access you know subtext
might be brought in I gotta say it's got
some of the weirdest cast I've ever seen
though you know it's like Jamie Foxx and
jgl like that doesn't seem odd at all
rodrigo santoro not strange cool but
then you got MGK you got Casey nice -
alright sure know those directors
they're in touch with the youth okay
they made all those found-footage movies
and so they gotta you know bring some
people in for the kids keep it hip not
that familiar with Dominic Fischbach but
I know she's a rising star so this cast
Wow and it's funny cuz I haven't seen
Joseph gordon-levitt in a hot minute
like I feel like he's kind of let
himself fall off the radar or at least
the main public eye yeah and are for a
little while it's cool to see him come
back with something like this and be
refreshed by like oh yeah it's been a
minute since I've seen you and he also
does look a little bit yeah so you know
it could be kind of an evolution for him
too in terms of breaking out of that
boyish mold well I'm excited that Jamie
Foxx is doing this because he stepped in
to the superhero scene with the amazing
spider-man - oh yeah and everyone's and
wanted him to do another superhero
movies actually he is that same
character and he's just pissed because
now he doesn't have his powers anymore
and he wants an axe kill spider-man
I mean he looks super badass in here and
his character I reminds me of like the
sleepless role in this movie sleepless
baby driver and a little bit at the
beginning of his Horrible Bosses
I was just thinking about that whole
scene where he explains his name but I'm
not gonna tuck guard in this video all
right guys what did you think of this
trailer leave your thoughts down below
are you excited for it subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
bell this might be one of those Netflix
movies we actually do a review up check
us out on the Stardust app last but not
least it's two up
Chris wham off if there's anyone at our
patreon page who is like a superhero who
really goes out of his way to be as much
of a savior for the people to really go
into the communities and help out
strangers people who are in need I'm not
bullshitting you here he really is the
guy we're not talking about us yeah it
gets physically involved killed do a
wide variety of things and many
activists ways I feel like I be I'd feel
like less the van if I'm around the guy
yet I'd feel like he's not judging me
that's the best kind of person yeah they
inspire I guess this is what Irene
inspired feels like when you're I could
be more but I don't feel judged by you
Chris my mom provides that feeling so
Chris thank you for being you and I
wanted to give you a personal direct
shout out like this as yours wants to
shout out some type of other individual
or organization I have to thank you for
all the hard work you're doing and you
still persist you never have an excuse
to stop and that's what's so beautiful
about you dude foxie